Một chiến đe ba truyền thống nhé nước Ivan Dự Thìm.
Nếu này đã phóng các tây luật đầu tiên về phía SROW,
sau khi ọn Một Cà Ba khảm ơn này được bao làm lãnh tủ tôi ca mới.
Theo đại truyền nghi ví vép,
các quả tây luật đường phóng cho con khổ cơ được tấn công tiếp theo của chính sĩ quân sử,
giới lực lộn về vinh kinh mạng hủ giáo y văn chỉnh 2.
Chuy đó, lực lộn về vinh kinh mạng hủ giáo y văn chủ biết đã tìm anh cứ được tấn công,
bằng tây luận nhằm vào thành khổ trên đa viết.
Hủ bằng xa mạng như Epoys ROW và một số khăn tự thung con mỹ trải trung đâm.
Theo ra khẳng đến các đợt tập kích nằm trong lần sống tấn công thứ 2 chiến,
của chính sĩnh mang tên lời hồi đích thực bốn,
đồng thời chuy biết đã sự giộng một số loại tây luật thể hệ mới.
Ở chung lại của đời SROW thu gáo,
đã tiên hành các khổ không kích nhằm vào lĩnh cơ sở.
Mà nước này cho là hạ tăng lý quả đến chính quyền Iran,
tại khu vực miền chung.
Ê SROW cũng chưa biết đã tấn công một cơ sở được mua tả là trục sở hành không bú chủ
của lực hưởng về bình kích mạng hồi sau Iran,
tại tây luận.
Chúc khi đó, trên đồng ý đưa tên Washington và Trà Nó Víc đang tích được thảo luận.
Khả năng chiến khai chính sịch, nhằm kiểm soát khó Rã Nương làm giấu cao của Iran,
theo các ngon tên một số phương anh được xem sét bao gồm,
đưa vật liệu hạm nhân ra khỏi lĩnh tử Iran,
học bầu hiệu hạm ngày tại tây luận hạp Yên của lĩnh này.